Speaker 1: Mike Pillow, the CEO and
founder of MyPillow, Mike Lindell.
He was also at the Trump rally. This is the
last element of the Trump rally we're going
to look at today. He arrived in Ohio for
the rally. He was completely out of breath,
and he again seems to be talking about
lawsuits against machines. Remember,
he wants to sue every machine.
Speaker 4: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I actually
I have a computer monitor that has gone into
witness protection because it is very much afraid
of this pillow lawsuit. Listen to this guy.
Speaker 4: Yesterday was a historical
day in the history of America.
Speaker 1: Well, yeah, I mean,
every day is historical. That's true.
Speaker 4: We filed the first
preliminary injunction in the state of Arizona
to get rid of the machines once and for all.
And that's the first of many, many. I want
to do all 50 Kerry Lake and Mark Finchem,
where the plaintiffs, Benjamin and the defendant
is Katie Hobbs, the Secretary of state, and Mary
Maricopa County and Pima County
County Commissioners. And so
and our commissioners, I think they are.
And this is so important because, yeah,
Speaker 1: it really sounds like any day now
they're going to put Trump back in office.
This guy has a following. Trump praises him at
every single one of his rallies. Here he is.
Talking about the masks on planes coming off
have have really reinvigorated a lot of people.
Speaker 4: All the other judges, how would
you like to have been a judge back then? Had
been the first one to step forward and
have your family attacked or whatever?
Yeah, they lived in fear. But you know, since we
all know the evidence is there and everything,
the judges are going to be brave. Remember that
Donald Trump appointed over. I think it was almost
five hundred judges look at what one just did down
in Florida. Was that amazing? They ordered the
mail scorn on the airplanes. It's beautiful. You
know, one judge to say the change of yeah, right.
And this is what's going to happen with these
preliminary injunction. The judges are going
to start pouring in on saying, we can't have
these corrupt machines where, you know, we're
a country. When you're in a country where end
Speaker 1: machines, it must be it, by way. Why
can't you add a breath of eliminare a junction?
It's it's all bizarre here. He claims Trump
really won Ohio by three point four million,
which would be an extra half million votes for
Trump. Where did those come from? We don't know
Speaker 4: in the next great state of Ohio.
The Big Lie, which is the big lie, they say.
Donald Trump won by four hundred and seventy
five thousand votes, it with fewer machines
and with everything it went on, you guys said
supposedly pretty good voting rolls. Well, that's
not true. Dr. Frank went over all your stuff.
Speaker 1: By the way, for people listening, the
reason pillow screaming is there's like a crowd
that has kind of gathered to listen to them
Speaker 4: in the state of Ohio. Donald Trump
really won three million four hundred thousand
to two million four hundred and thirty thousand.
That's another 500000 votes that were stolen.
Speaker 1: Yep. So that's completely made
up. And then lastly, here is pillow actually
addressing the rally crowd. And here he says,
we've got to get back to God.
Speaker 4: We're living in the
greatest time in history because everything
is getting revealed when we get through this.
It's going to be the most beautiful place.
We're going to have fair elections. We're
going to put God back in our schools and
we will once again be one nation under God.
Speaker 1: And of course, putting God back
into schools would go completely against
the Constitution of the United States
and separation of church and state. So
this man is a hero in a normal timeline
and a normal universe. Nobody would ever
have voted for Trump. And people like pillow
would never be revered as heroes. But alas,
we are not in normal times, and these are
the heroes that the right wing cult has